as the Black Friday shopping rush begins
major retailers are looking for new ways
to use technology to compete with online
competitors total retail sales in the
five days around Thanksgiving excluding
cars and fuel are expected to reach one
hundred and forty four billion dollars
fifteen percent of those sales will be
online tonita copal visited the
country's largest retailer that's
walmart to see if the blend of
technology and tradition this Walmart in
Rogers Arkansas looks like the store
you've been shopping at for years
well almost America's largest retailer
is hoping to stay on top bringing a dose
of online convenience to old-fashioned
offline shopping this holiday season
every aisle can be the checkout aisle I
would like Saturday Night Fever no bag
can go bingo and if you're tired of
getting lost in giant stores well
Walmart says it has a solution type say
instant pot into your Walmart app and
your phone will guide you to it there is
Isle h20 yeah so let's go get it we have
it on feature and if you'd rather not
wait for your online order to come to
you you can come to it by using one of
these pickup towers get a barcode
Walmart smart if it's in give us a demo
it is as simple as scan the barcode
little message saying retrieving the
item you can't wait clunking away in the
background not sure it should be
clunking well there you go look at that
and within seconds there you go there's
your purchase thing I wonder is there a
little person in there absolutely not
a mana dance with me of course Walmart
isn't the only retailer selling
convenience these days thanks to
curbside pickup Nordstrom and target
customers don't have to leave the car
and Home Depot shoppers can skip the
line by picking up their order from
in-store lockers holiday sales are gonna
go up again
absolutely USA Today national business
correspondent Cherise Jones Amazon
revolutionized retail by making shopping
so easy so fast so convenient
and I think traditional retailers are
really having to roll out this
technology and be very savvy on smart
phones to kind of attract those shoppers
that they're losing to Amazon those
stores are giving customers more options
the popularity of online shopping is
growing glass Thanksgiving weekend
people spent nineteen point six billion
dollars online that's up more than two
billion dollars from just the year
before but even so Jones believes
traditional retailers will always have
one comforting advantage when it comes
to holiday shopping literally every year
for the last twenty years you know
mothers and grandmothers and daughters
line up they've got their hot coffee
what's this ritual that a lot of people
embrace as much as the turkey and the
pumpkin pie and for all the shoppers out
there we urge you not to splurge too
much on a holiday dream item according
to Jones about 25% of people are still
paying off debt from last year for CBS
this morning Tony - copal Rogers
Arkansas so you you weren't you weren't
feeling it the technology the mix of
technology not ready for it - Jetsons
and Jones you know what I mean there
stay home and online or I want to go we
were saying touch everything yes the
in-store all places where you can touch
things and put them in bag and take them
- I do like the wrapping function though
as you know most guys are in that - like
I used tinfoil do not do the wrap as
well as I love Tecopa buying Saturday
Night Fever yeah the vinyl edition
budget